[Music]
all right hello everybody and welcome to
my first lecture in what i hope will be
a thematic
series of lectures throughout my tenure
here as a gm in residence
and
the the theme of these lectures is going
to
have to do with um planning ahead sort
of building a plan
in chess and
you know to me this is like one of the
hardest things to do
not even talking about like the right
plan just finding a plan even if it's
not the best or sometimes wrong it's a
very difficult thing to do because it
requires you
to really get to the bottom of things in
a position and realize what's important
so that's the exercise that we're going
to be uh
getting at in these two games that i
prepared for today now this first game
is a game i played fairly recently at an
open in florianopolis brazil
against a very strong player the number
one ranked player in argentina and
this game went e4 e5
and we quickly went into a rui lopez
variation
and since i
correctly it turns out assume that my
opponent would be better prepared than
me
i decided to play
a fairly
uh
i wouldn't say
unusual
but it's certainly a variation that is
not at the peak of its popularity for
black so i thought i would catch my
opponent a little bit off guard and i
especially like
the the positional
battles that tend to result from this
opening so white played d4 and after b5
bishop b3
d5 black's idea is to give back the pawn
in order to reach this position so this
is basically the starting position of
what's known as the open morphe
variation
or the open relopus you can pick your
name
but basically
what's going on here
is that black has created
a break in the symmetry
because black will now have a pawn
majority on the queen side and white
will have a pawn majority on the king
side
so
one of the the most common themes
in these middle games are who's going to
get there first is black going to get to
play c5 or is white going to get to play
f4 it's really kind of an open
question we haven't really gotten
a definitive answer and um
i think i have a hunch that black is
doing fine here and this is why i play
the line so anyway
white has a lot of options
i don't want to dwell too much on the
opening
in this game white shows the absolute
main line
which is c3
preparing a timely knight d4 right
because the point is to get these pawns
rolling as quickly as possible so after
c3
bishop c5 knight d2
and castle kingside black also has other
ways of playing sometimes the bishop
goes to e7 the knight goes to c5
but this this opening had caught my
attention
because
after the move bishop c2
the first important step for white is to
get rid of my knight on e4 this is
probably my most aggressive piece
and what's holding white back from
freely moving this knight away from f3
and playing f4 f5 so for example if um
if white
were to
force me to take on d2
after something like bishop takes d2
um
i don't i just want to make a couple of
random moves for black to to illustrate
a point
white will
try to get
seized control over d4 maybe with a move
like
um i don't know if queen e2 would work
and if rook d8
something like bishop e3 i don't know if
i should throw b4 in or not
but
let's say
i arrive at a position like this knight
takes pawn takes this is white's dream
come true
because
i've clamped down on the c5 square it
means you're not going to get to do what
you want and i'm ready to start pushing
f4 f5
these kinds of changes in the position
are exactly what white is looking for
and black needs to avoid
so of course both sides could have
played a lot better here
i'm not going to dwell on it but now we
have a visual
on
what to do and what not to do
black's idea is absolutely radical here
the point is
to take on f2
and create a further imbalance in the
position this time the imbalance is not
going to be about the pawn structure
it's not going to be about
who has the pawn majority where it's
going to be a material imbalance because
after rook takes f2
we're going to get a situation where
black is going to get a rook
and
we'll see two pawns
for two minor pieces and rook versus
minor pieces is one of the oldest
strategic themes in the book
and when i choose an opening
i want to choose okay what kind of theme
is going to predominate in this game
so after f6
white played knight f1 which i think is
the best move you might be thinking well
why would i give you my e5 pawn why can
i just take on f6 well after bishop
takes king takes
queen takes f6 if you go knight f1 now
turns out black's position is really
rolling here after knight e5 i got
bishop g4 coming i've got knight takes
f3 i've got queen h4
so many moves it looks like black's
pieces are just swarming towards the
white king so
this is not the line that worries me
when i play this position with black
the line that worries me is the one that
white played in this game knight f1
because now white is threatening to play
bishop e3
and keep the rook
so after bishop takes f2 king takes f2
f takes e5
we get
to the position that i wanted to discuss
today so everything up until now has
been
sort of a preface leading up to
this moment
so
black has
rook
and two pawns
against
bishop
and knight
how would you guys evaluate this
position who do you think
has the better of it
and why because remember that the goal
of this lecture
is to work on our planning right we want
to build a plan
what is a plan in chess a plan is simply
a sketch of the position
that shows you where each piece wants to
go and what target those pieces are
going to be working together on right so
in this position let's say we'll make
one more move for white because it's
kind of an obvious move black is
threatening e4 the knight is pinned so
so white has to go king g1
so i would say this is the starting
position so any
any takers here as to
you know when you look at this
what you feel do you feel more attracted
towards black's position towards white's
position
are there any
uh certain virtues or problems that you
see with either side
yeah
i
would prefer black i mean because it's
uh a material plus um
i mean my most uh
most counts of the yeah that's fair and
then also i mean you have this
dangerous
uh
[Music]
right so you're up material and you have
you know this past pawn so
it seems like
it's up to white
to to compensate right to say okay yes
you have these things
but there's an underlying problem with
your position that i can take advantage
of with the minor pieces so those are
definitely
the trumps that black has but what are
some problems that black is going to be
dealing with so so who is willing to
play you know devil's advocate here and
and maybe defend white a little bit
he's got the bishop
yes that's absolutely true right these
bishops are pointing straight at our
king side so we need to be very careful
and
anything else
i think that's pretty good i think
that's a pretty good outline right black
has
extra material
and very interesting control over the
center
but white has
some serious potential for an attack on
the king side so
how would you handle this position as
black i mean you you mentioned you like
black's position what would your next
moves be
or at least
which moves jump out at you like
what do you want to see happen in the
next three or four moves
okay this is fantastic right we would
love to do this because the pawn on e4
would shut down the bishop on c2 right
so it would no longer
have such an extensive reach towards our
king
um
if our knight could get to e5
that would be great because then maybe
we could move our c pawn forward and
then we would achieve our ultimately
open morphe
goal which is to mobilize our queen sign
black almost always
wins the game on the queen side we need
to remember that because that
line was drawn in the sand very early on
in the game
so i think you really hit sort of the
key
theme here black wants to go e4 knight
e5 the question is
why can't we just do it right away or
can we maybe we can
do you see any any immediate problems
with this
okay and how is this a problem
yeah i mean this is strategically
devastating for us right we didn't get
our knight to e5 our pawn gets fixed on
c7 meaning you know we're never going to
be able to play c5
and that's it we're stopped dead on our
tracks white's next moves are going to
be probably bishop e3 knight g3 rook c1
and this is just a nightmare
where sitting ducks is black so
this is what black needs to be careful
with black cannot afford
a bad trade
or
having the c pawn sort of locked in
place but really the the trading of the
knight is is crucial here
so
now that we know what our north star is
how can we try to get there
so e4 was one candidate move didn't
quite work so let's instead of giving up
on it and just tossing it
let's
tweak it a little bit right so how can
we improve that idea
how can we prepare it
bishop g4
okay i actually played a game this is
one of my first games
in this line where i i did go bishop g4
and this looks at first it just looks
devastating because we're about to take
on f3 we're going to break up
white's king side pawn structure expose
this king even further
but this is going to reveal
a hidden drawback in black's position
because let's say you go bishop g4 right
and let's say i go 93
what's your next move
i would think you you would have to go
bishop takes f3 just to be consistent
because
i'm otherwise threatening to take your
d5 pawn and going back to e6 you just
wasted two moves so after bishop takes
f3 g takes f3
what problem
arises here
does anybody
[Music]
yeah i mean why does black have to deal
with here
well do you think this is a problem for
black
let's say quite the opposite right it's
like the only good thing black has going
for no i mean you you have a huge
problem with your d5 pawn not only that
your e4 95 idea just went out the window
right so you would probably have to play
something like 97
but
here
this is this is a very passive
alternative to what we were just talking
about it looks like white's just going
to seize the initiative maybe something
like
queen d3 and after g6 the knight's
coming to g4 and what you mentioned
earlier right about white's bishop
pointing at our king side turns out to
be a very serious very real problem
white has a crushing position here
everything has
failed for black
so
bishop g4
move that's hard to resist
but a move that exposes how delicate
this center is right this is not
um this can be a strength for black but
it can be a liability as well so we need
to tend to this center we need to
reinforce it be and stabilize it before
we can move on the offensive right these
moves are very aggressive moves but our
position is simply not ready for that
kind of aggression yet we need to build
up our position
so in the chat here there's an
interesting suggestion actually it's a
terrible suggestion it's what i played
which is a mistake but it's in it's a
good place to start
the move queen f6
and
queen f6
it's actually not obvious why this is a
mistake
but
realizing why queen f6 is a mistake will
help us understand the next game i want
to show you which is a recent game that
magnus carlsen played so that's just a
little teaser for what's coming up in
just a few minutes but
what could be the drawback behind the
move queen f6
and actually
let me rephrase that question
we just spent some time
figuring out what black's plan was right
and we said well we really want to play
e4 and 95. and there's a problem with
knight d4 so we
we kind of have to address that all
right and queen f6
seeks to address that by defending the
bishop so right after
e4 knight d4
not only can i play knight e5 but i can
also consider ideas like queen f2 check
and i have some pressure on the f file
so that's the basic
idea of queen f6 so for example
if something like bishop e3
i was going to play
e4 and after knight d495 this was my my
big idea
because i don't really care about having
this bishop traded off
i care about having this knight on e5
and this pawn on e4 so this was the
position that that i was hoping to get
as black
but what i failed to do was put to put
myself in white's shoes just like i
figured out okay what is my plan
i didn't ask myself well what does white
want to do what is white's next four or
five moves going to look like so
can anybody sort of
sketch out
an outline of where white's p where you
would like white's pieces to go
because this is the plan
that later is going to serve as our road
map to navigate a very complex middle
game
so
okay so
knight to g5 is this
a plan or is this just like a forced
sequence that you see like okay i can
win something
he's looking at knight here
queen
queen to h5 you know kind of trying to
because your bishops are like you know
you can potentially sacrifice on an h7
potentially kind of opening up something
so they're not i don't see the
okay now but when you look at a move
like knight g5 is there anything that
you're concerned about is white or is
there anything that you're neglecting
by choosing
knight g5
what's that h6
like if you go knight g5 i could go h6
but you know maybe then you take on e6
or you go knight h7 i don't think that's
really
what the trade-off right because knight
g5 what you're doing is you're moving a
piece you've already moved right so
that comes at the expense of some other
piece that deserves attention and is not
getting it
so
knight g5 comes at the expense of what
yes it happens it just so happens that
you're getting checkmated right
but even if you miss this tactic
right queen f2 check king h1 and queen
takes f1 which is force checkmate even
if you missed that
there should be something suspicious
about knight g5 because
you still have a totally underdeveloped
queen side
right it's like
you know this bishop is a problem and
you don't know how to solve it so you
figure hey
i'll just deal with that later right
like why would i worry about a problem
now and that's sort of a
subconscious way of thinking like you're
like oh but i i want to i want to play
knight g5 so
if i have to choose between doing what i
want to do and dealing with a problem
i'll just do what i want
that doesn't work out so well in the
long run so
it's important to
identify the biggest problem that you
have and solve that first now of course
if knight g5 were to win immediately you
would be right
but it doesn't
so this is white's big problem
and we need to sketch out
a plan for white
that
puts this dark square bishop as this
sort of centerpiece
we want our greatest weakness to become
our greatest source of pride in the
position
so
can anybody take another shot at this
okay and where's that bishop going let's
say i go queen f7
okay and that that might be threatening
finally you know the knight g5 so let's
say i go like h6
bingo right that's the key
the key maneuver in this position is to
reroute the bishop from c1
all the way back to g3 g3 is the golden
square because from there the bishop
bishop's going to cover f2 so you never
run into queen f2 check again the
bishop's going to put pressure on e5
it's going to control the e5 square
making your e4 95 idea a lot harder
if not impossible
and it's going to be out of the way
right it's going to let you continue
improving your position right so this is
going to be one piece of the puzzle but
it's the biggest piece
so let's keep
building our plan with white right so
we've
we found a key idea bishop h g5 h4 g3
what about the other pieces where is
everything else going to go
and remember you want your pieces to
have
purpose right you don't just want to
develop them for the sake of development
saying okay the night is out so now it's
the night's problem he's got to fend for
himself
you want to sink your teeth into
something that's wrong with your
opponent's position you want to sort of
peel away
at weakness until it just becomes
a hole in the wall right
too big to ignore so
let's say we magically get our bishop to
g3 okay that's done where is everything
else gonna go what
target can white find
any ideas back there
well in the chat there's a suggestion
for a4
and i don't really think i think a4 is
kind of a way of delaying the question
one more move because you're not really
telling me like where your pieces are
going to go
so
this bishop and this knight to me those
are the big
uh enigmas
in white's position like what are these
pieces doing
they're not really doing anything they
look fine they look like they're out of
the way
but
where is
the pressure like what have you done for
me lately bishop on c2 and knight on f1
nothing so how can we
give purpose to these two pieces
excellent and now your pieces are
converging
over a common target
so from being scattered right bishop
around here knight around here queen
here all of a sudden they they go in
like v formation right towards this d5
pawn so this is the essence of white's
position
white wants to get a bishop to g3 bishop
to b3 knight to e3 and the game is over
if that happens because white's
sorry black's center just begins to
collapse
so
that brings us back to my wonderful
queen f6 move why is this such a bad
move
what what what do you usually need to do
to win a chess game by the way
just in general
what's that
have tempo what does that mean you're on
the initiative you're attacking they're
defending okay but i think you can go
even deeper than that right because when
you have the initiative
when you're attacking you're doing
something you're putting your opponent
in in a very specific situation which is
you're creating problems for your
opponent your opponent has to solve a
problem he has to make a decision
you can only make mistakes
when you have a decision to make
right if you force your opponent to make
only move after only move it's very hard
for your opponent to make a mistake
right he's just gonna oh it's the only
move fantastic and as anan said
only moves are always good moves right
so if you're forcing your opponent to
make the best move all of the time
you're gonna be like geez this game is
really hard to win
so
what you want to do
is
put your opponent in a situation where
he has to make a decision
when i play the move queen f6
from a strategic point of view this is a
big mistake
because i'm not making it harder for
white to carry out his plan right this
is his dream
oops i went a little too far with that
arrow this is his dream scenario and i
should be making this harder for him and
queen f6 is basically an invitation
saying hey that's a really good plan let
me help you out and and get your bishop
to g3 as soon as possible so sure enough
he plays bishop g5 and after queen f7
bishop h4 so now knight g5 is a threat
so i have to play h6 and he goes bishop
g3 so
the hardest part of his plan he's
already accomplished
and i have very little to show for it
not only that
my e5 pawn is under attack
and if i go e4
now after knight d4 guess what
i don't have 95 so my entire plan is
falling apart so i was already in
trouble here
that's why i had to come up with a
radical solution and i played rook a d8
so here is where some interesting
tactical questions arise
what happens
if knight takes e5
how is black going to compensate for the
loss of this incredibly important pawn
i'm not sure i see some movement in the
back but it's really dark so i don't
know if it's a hand being raised or
somebody moving but does anybody in the
back have
an idea against knight takes e5
it's an idea that we've encountered
already right the weakness of this f2
square and how this king is a little bit
more exposed after knight takes bishop
takes
queen f2 king h1 and here it's where
it's like okay but now what where do i
go from here
because the check on f2 is scary but it
doesn't seem like there's anything too
terrible happening
you're definitely on to the right idea
but if
d4 let's say if i go c takes d4 i'll
sort of
indulge you yeah a little bit
yes and this is actually crushing now
black is winning
all of black's pieces are are doing a
great job there's no way to stop
uh
the capture on g2 now the problem is
that c takes d4 is not really a forced
move
right so here white can can use this
opportunity to launch a counter
offensive you could call it maybe white
could start with queen d3 or maybe white
could say let me kick this queen out
first
and then worry about taking on d4 so
d4 would be fantastic if you had one
more move but it's like you take your
foot off the gas just for one moment and
and white is able to
to strike back
but this idea of getting the bishop to
this diagonal is absolutely key so
what
more direct way
do you have
i see in the chat somebody is suggesting
the move bishop h3
it's a very nice idea but the problem is
after g takes you don't really have a
good follow-up right and you're still
going to get kicked out
any other
suggestions okay
interesting right because if queen takes
g4 then you again have this back rank
problem
and you get checkmated so i have to move
my queen away let's say i go queen c1
and now
you're so close
yeah i couldn't see the next move it
looked good
right so the the only way that you're
going to break through is by getting
into this diagonal
yes brilliant
bishop f3 it's only good enough for a
draw but considering how badly black
messed this up with queen f6 that's
that's pretty good right pawn takes
queen takes and perpetual
so
so it's kind of a defensive resource at
this point because black is just
fighting to stay in the game
okay uh bishop takes e5
is actually a lot worse because after
knight takes knight takes
queen f2 king h1
now
how can black play
come on man it's your time to shine
you got it yes now d4 is is fantastic
because again you know if c takes d4
bishop d5
that's lights out and if a queen d3 now
it's a very different situation because
you have bishop f5
and you're just going to take the bishop
on c2 and there's no um there's no
bishop g3 right kicking the queen out so
there's really no good way of stopping
bishop d5 maybe you have to do something
like bishop b3 but let's say after you
know takes takes and
king h7 for example you have some back
rank problems that are pretty serious
you have this d-pawn that's a pretty
serious problem
and overall i mean
black's position is just amazing so
the pawn on e5 cannot be captured this
is excellent news for black
so white plays
well what should white have played here
i remember i was very surprised with the
move my opponent played pleasantly
surprised
yeah right because that's the whole
reason why we drew this sketch of the
position it's to have a guideline like
we're like faced with this incredibly
complicated position you're like i don't
know which way is up which way is down
you always go back to your sketch right
okay what were the moves that i wanted
to play well can i play any of them here
so the candidate moves should be 93 and
bishop b3 right before you even start
looking at anything else
because this is what's going to complete
your plan
so i was expecting the move knight e3
and
my idea was to play d4 but here
i originally missed a very strong move
and after this move
black might
be losing
and this is probably a very important
subtlety between starting with knight e3
and starting with bishop b3 they are not
the same thing
no no after black plays d4 what can
white play here
well bishop b3 i'm just taking your
knight right
and attacking your queen that doesn't
seem like a very good deal
knight takes e5 i think i can just take
here and after bishop takes i still take
your knight
not to mention there's a check on f2
that might be interesting as always
any other ways of
sort of hammering away at a problem that
black has
i mean this goes back to the very
beginning like when when you said what
what are the
good things about white's position
the first thing that came up was that
the bishops are pointing at the black
king
queen to d3 of course right it's kind of
like the the natural follow-up to to
having the bishop point at the king get
the queen in there right so after queen
d3 i really have no good way of stopping
queen h7 i have to do some
painful move like g6 i remember in the
game i was looking at g5
and
the big problem i saw here was this
nasty in between move queen e4
because now after pawn takes knight
white takes here and my center is
collapsing right this is not what i had
in mind
so
i think white just missed this
luckily for me
and instead played queen d2
which
if you think about it doesn't make any
sense because it doesn't
fit in with any of the things that we
were talking about it doesn't help you
put pressure on d5 it doesn't help you
put pressure on this diagonal so it's
kind of a
an empty vessel of a move
it's a move that
okay you know the queen is better on d2
than it was on d1 but it has no real
purpose
so
after queen d2
i was able to play d4
and
now after bishop e4
here's where i had
my chance in the game i think after rook
d8 and d4 i was forced to change plans
right my original plan of going e4 95
it blew up in my face because queen f6
was the wrong way of going about it
instead
having forced my queen to f7 i figured
well
i should probably turn my attention to
the queen side immediately and that's
why i played for this d4 idea because
now there's pressure on a2 there's
pressure on the d file this queen turned
out to be
pretty seriously misplaced on d2
but black's next move is key in this
position so how would you guys play as
black
first of all this is a threat right so
we have to deal with that
so
a couple of options would be to play d
take c3 attacking the queen or bishop d5
blocking the threat on the knight
why
after queen takes c3 your knight's still
under attack
and now push the
well but i'm gonna take your knight
right i can play queen takes night
and and overall this
is a very
tricky trade for black right trading
this pawn that was restricting
white's position for this pawn on c3
that wasn't doing anything i think is a
pretty bad deal in general for black not
to mention that now
white has
all his artillery pointed at my e5 pawn
this is what i played by the way so
it wasn't this was strike two for me
the reason i played this was because i
felt i could solve the problem of my
knight in an active way by going knight
d4
and i figured well i'll just replenish
my
uh
my d4 pawn maybe i can go like e takes
d4
but actually i kind of gave up on this
because i didn't want to lose my pawn on
c7 although after bishop takes a2 i
think this is playable for black it's
not so easy but in the game i played
rook takes d4 which is a worse move and
after bishop f3
only now did i play bishop d5 but notice
how everything is kind of broken up now
this is a much sloppier center
for black
and once your center collapses it's the
beginning of the end
so the key move in this position was to
play bishop d5
destabilizing
white's clamp over the center and now if
bishop takes d5 queen oops queen takes
d5
this is not an easy position for white
i mean i'm not sure what white would
play maybe if white tries to put more
pressure on e5
then you can easily start to see things
like this
happening
right i have this amazing pawn if you
take on e5 well that's
that's fantastic news
but
maybe i'll just play like c5 c4 and and
this pawn on d3 is just going to tie you
down for the rest of the game
right and and then i can start playing
on the queen side as well so so black is
much much better in these kinds of
positions
unfortunately i took on c3 and after
queen takes knight d4
i i wasn't able to tie white's pieces
down anywhere near
that position we were just looking at
with the pawn on d3
so
bishop d5 was too little too late
and i made a couple of
bad decisions down the line i arrived at
this end game and actually
uh things went relatively well for me
here
but now i made
the strategic blender that lost the game
so i want to see if you guys
can find the right plan for black it's a
very delicate position for black but
black is absolutely fine here
so white is threatening rook takes c5
how would you deal with this and if
you're about to say c4 you better
start thinking that there might be
something wrong with that because it's
the obvious move
so in the chat there's one suggestion of
defending the pawn with rook c8
i don't really think this is going to
solve the problem because
there's an issue here that has to do
with planning
right
white's minor pieces have no purpose
they're not doing anything so white
needs to solve this problem immediately
because
i'm really rolling you know my rook
might come to d1
if i can start pushing my pawns get a
pass pawn maybe a rook behind the pawn
i have a very clear plan i want to
promote my c pawn i want to play rook c8
you know c4 b4 c3 and the game is is
basically over
so white needs to step up and counter
this and
the secret to doing that lies
with the recycling of these minor pieces
c4 the move i played is a strategic
blunder
because once again
i failed to think like what is my
opponent trying to do how is he trying
to rearrange his pieces like when i
played queen f6 i allowed white to go
bishop g5 and put the bishop on g3
without a fight so what
move
can white play here
robert can you scroll up a little bit
yes
what move can white play that will
improve white's position but at the same
time it will deal a devastating blow to
my plan
right of doing this
this and this
in the chat somebody's saying knight h4
well this has nothing to do with what's
going on the queen side so that's
not going to be the move
also you're working on a sort of self
mate there eventually when i go work d1
brilliant
bishop e1
now the bishop's coming to c3 and after
a3 white has a total clamp on the queen
side my pawns are not going anywhere
right so it completely kills
my counter play so that's why c4 is a
mistake now we need to find an
improvement
by the way rook c8 the move previously
mentioned doesn't work because
now bishop e1 is actually not as good
why not
what have
what does having the pawn still on c5
allow me to do that i couldn't do with
the pawn on c4
v4 yes b4 this is key
because it prevents the bishop from
getting to where it wants to go
and
this is actually a difficult position
for white because white can never really
coordinate the minor pieces the way that
he would like to the bishop on e1 is
awkward
so so that was the key right to
keep the pawn on c5 in case that bishop
tries to make its way back to c3 now
the reason that i don't like rook c8 so
much is because after rook e7 the bishop
is still going to find its way to this
diagonal and it's going to put some
pretty nasty pressure on g7
so
the best move
i think is just to
you could throw in a check but it's
probably going to transpose to go b4
and now
give up the c5 pawn and instead
pick up the b2 pawn so you just change
the nature of your pawn majority instead
of having a three against two you have a
two against one which actually makes
your pawn majority stronger
and i don't know if something like rook
a5 then you start bringing your rook
into the game you know takes and
at the very least you can take on g2 you
can give a check
black is doing okay
so
you know this was
not an easy move to find we're just like
oh whatever just take my most important
pawn
so
but after c4 this is just
completely hopeless i'll just show you
a few more moves but you can start to
see
how black's position just starts to die
out right after a3 you can tell nothing
nothing's happening here
and in the meantime
white has all the potential right white
is going to go
rook d6 maybe bring the king up maybe
get the knight involved so
sky's the limit for white's pieces my
rooks are all tapped out like i
i couldn't tell you a good square for my
rooks
so
played rookie 6 king e8 rook c1
trying to cut the king off and
uh
after rook d7 i'm already in some weird
mating net here
and that's going to happen very soon
right here
takes and now the king joins in so
now check
king g6 and i'm just getting mated
right because now if rookie 8
96 king g8 and checkmate okay
so
that's sort of the first game and now
that we have that as sort of a backdrop
i'm going to show you this position from
carlson neiman which was played in a
rapid tournament that's still going on
called the charity cup
and this game is only a couple of of
days old
and uh
i remember after losing my game i was
like i can't believe i i always play
these terrible lines that nobody plays
and then you know this game happens and
they reach the exact same position so i
was like okay well these guys are pretty
good so maybe the line's not so bad
so
we know that e4
premature we know that bishop g4
neglects the center we know that queen
f6 does not anticipate
white's plan it actually encourages it
so
neiman plays the right move this
position he plays queen d6
and this is a key move
because
it reinforces the center it defends the
bishop therefore it prepares
e4 followed by knight e5
and now
carlson plays bishop g5 this move is
actually a novelty but after having
discussed our game we can see that
bishop g5 actually makes a lot of sense
carlson is just trying to get to g3 to
put pressure on e5
by the way you might say well this is a
novelty well what did white do before
this
white still tried to get the same idea
but tried to get to g3 this way which is
reasonable right there's nothing wrong
with this
but carlson goes for g5 because he wants
to keep the e3 square for the knight
and now after e4 knight d4 95
things are go are flowing
much better for black
knight e3
bishop d7 black is keeping all the
pieces on the board and
c5
is coming so white needs to be very
careful because these pieces
do not have enough
they're not anchored right they don't
have enough protection
from attacked by black's pawns
so
white plays bishop h4
and the next move is going to be bishop
g3
so i'm going to give you two moves here
as black
c5 and queen h6
which one would you play
there are more moves but i think these
are the the critical choices
any votes
let's take a survey here
so so who who goes for queen h6
one
is it one or am i missing someone i
think it's one and what about
c5
okay so c5 definitely takes the cake
also in the chat most people are
suggesting c5
and c5 is the right move i mean
if you can play c5 you should do it
because it's your entire plan right
since you played this variation
it's built on the assumption that you're
going to be able to to play on the queen
side and the only way
or the most effective way of doing that
is by pushing c5 so unless there's
something really really wrong with this
you go for it
and really the knight has to is driven
back i don't know if carlson thought
maybe he could go bishop g3 anyway
and if c takes c takes but actually now
queen h6 is devastating because you
unpin the queen while you attack the
knight at the same time
so that doesn't work
another idea that i thought was
interesting was bishop b3 the other key
move part of white's plan notice how
these are kind of tactical nuances but
at the same time they fit in perfectly
with the plan that we laid out for white
so it's not a coincidence
that your most interesting
tactical ideas
happen to fall perfectly in place
with the general sketch of the position
that you laid out
so the point of bishop b3 is that now if
you take the knight
i can take on d5 and after king h8 i can
take the rook and after rook takes
i can i don't know just take on d4
i don't know this position to me
looks absolutely fine for black right
this knight on d3 is a monster
so
c5 was the key move
neiman played queen h6 and this is a
losing move so now it's white to play
and win
so i'll give you guys a chance to think
for a minute here
okay and if i take your bishop
that looks pretty good for black because
i'm also going to come into f2 after
that right so so not knight takes d5
anybody else
they they found it in the chat
the big problem with queen h6 is that it
neglects something that we've touched on
that's very important right a part of
black's position that's particularly
vulnerable and that is the center right
this center that that we've been
arguing whether it's a strength or a
weakness for black really it can be
either one up until the very end
but
if you don't
tend to it with your pieces as black
it's going to fall apart and here
you're right to think that knight takes
d5 that should be
sort of in the general direction where
you're aiming at
but unfortunately your bishop hangs
the the winning move
is knight
f5
because it's not the knight that wants
to capture on d5 it's the queen the
queen is going to be much more
devastating it's going to check the king
it's going to attack the knight the
bishop and the rook
so
the trick is that after bishop takes f5
i just go knight takes f5 again
i'm defending the bishop
i'm attacking the queen and if you go
rook takes f5 i just go queen takes d5
and then i take on a8 and this is
actually checkmate so the game is over
so here you're in a huge uh you have a
huge problem you're about to lose your
d5 pawn and your queen is hanging so it
would seem like queen e6 is the only
move
and now how does white put this away
and if king h8
correct but come on this doesn't just
look cooler it does yeah
so you know
and besides you showed me a game where
you you'd appreciate you know a cool
finish right
so
um i think queen takes d5 is pretty
awesome because if queen takes check
then you take here and the center
collapses and the game is over right you
could you can't even fight it because e3
i just take it
um so anyway after knight
takes f5 or knight f5 the center
collapses and that's why queen h6 was a
mistake you
you didn't build up your center enough
to relieve your queen of those duties so
neiman just
tried to desperate move knight f3
probably his only chance
and after queen takes queen b6 queen e3
rook takes f5
and now the problem is that
white inflicts this devastating change
to black's pawn structure because now
without a c pawn you can never
support your d5 pawn and also you can
never play c5 and d4 so your pawns are
stuck
so now bishop f2
hits b6 contains the pawns
rook b8 rook d1
king f7
bishop v3 king e6 and rook d4 and the
center collapses right i'm threatening
rook takes e4 and you have no good
squares for the king right if you go
here
peekaboo
and
if you go anywhere else i just take on
d5
so
the game went on a few more moves i'll
actually show
the entire game because it really wasn't
that long
but anyway the bishops basically
just
tore black's position apart and noticed
that
the center has completely vanished now
right so
it's no surprise that like one move
after the center is gone
uh black just resigned here you can't
stop either
me taking on h7 or coming after your a6
pawn or most likely both so anyway i
just wanted to to show you these two
games because i have a little bit of my
my own experience mixed in there so i
can give you my impressions of the
position but also it's a position
that two of the world's best players
right now
uh tried out just a couple days ago so
it's uh i really enjoy
sort of seeing what these guys are doing
and then if i get a chance just try to
do it too and so i feel like well i'm on
the same page you know i know what
they're talking about but um overall i
think it's a fascinating
opening i think it doesn't get nearly as
much attention
as it deserves and i hope you guys um
enjoyed our little conversation here so
thanks
[Music]
you